being a celebrity might seem like the
best thing in the world and it certainly
comes with plenty of perks however there
is also a dark side to being a public
figure one far too common issue comes
with stalkers this is something that has
affected K Reeves during his career the
Hollywood report revealed in early 2023
that the actor secured a temporary
restraining order in Los Angeles against
an alleged stalker according to court
documents the 38-year-old man reportedly
turned up at ree's home and harassed him
multiple times police investigation
confirmed the person that trespassed at
the actor's house in Los Angeles at
least six times at one point leaving
behind the DNA kit that he intended to
use to try and prove he and Reeves are
related